foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled an
overview of gene therapy manufacturing
development through commercial
production
this webinar is a part of the fourth
annual bioprocessing virtual event
I'm Angelina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots now let's get
started before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find the live chat located at the right
of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speakers Dr Samir
acharya associate director of process
development at andelan biosciences and
Dr Kevin G McGary Jr manager of
analytical development also at andolan
science
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr acharya and Dr McGarry you may now
begin your presentation
good morning everyone thank you for that
introduction my name is Kevin McGarry
and with me
for this presentation is samiracharya
we worked for andelan biosciences and we
would like to present an overview of
gene therapy manufacturing from the
development through the commercial
production of a geotherapy product
this talker we are going to present
today is for educational purposes
and I would be remiss not to mention our
copyright notice
that the following presentation is
copyrighted by Handel and biosciences
unless otherwise noted
and therefore must not be able to be
reproduced without
consent from handling biosciences
during today's talk
we would like to discuss what team
therapy is
what the steps involved for getting a
gene therapy product
development through the clinic are
and
this includes early development the
manufacturing processes the analytics
Associated during development through
release testing
and then the potential challenges
associated
with the production of a gene therapy
product
so first what is gene therapy gene
therapy is a field
that uses techniques to modify a
person's teams to treat or cure diseases
and Gene therapies work by a number of
different mechanisms first you could
replace a disease-causing gene with a
healthy of a copy Gene a healthy copy of
a new Gene or you can inactivate a
disease-causing gene that is not
functioning properly
alternatively you could introduce a new
or modified gene into the body to help
treat a disease
to do any of these different techniques
there are a number of different products
and techniques available first
you could use direct plasmid DNA
you could use viral vectors bacterial
vectors
human gene editing technology such as
crispr or patient-derived cellular gene
therapy products for the purposes of
this talk we will be focusing on viral
vectors specifically
several viral vectors that are used in
the gene therapy field include
adenovirus retroviruses which include
lentiviruses as well as adeno-associated
viruses each of these viruses have pros
and cons associated with them
adenoviruses lentiviruses and other
retroviruses all have
um
the potential for different size
payloads but do present
different side effects
including immunogenic response and an
inflammatory response additionally as
we're aware all viruses can infect or
viruses can infect individuals
and so specificity is also a a point to
be made on these further retroviruses
LNG viruses
have the ability to integrate into the
Genome of the organism it infects so
that's specificity component is very
very important
now
had no Associated virus is the virus
that we will be focusing our talk on
mostly today at no Associated virus was
discovered in 1965. it was originally
thought that it was a contaminant
um in an adenovirus prep
um but it turns out it is a standalone
virus
and from 1965 through 1983
the nucleotide sequence was discovered
as well as cloning techniques for aav2
and once this
was all discovered in the 15 to 20 years
Post Its Originals Discovery the field
of clean therapy exploded
I had no Associated virus is a small
single stranded DNA virus that can be
used as a transduction vector in gene
therapy
uh via various delivery mechanisms as a
delivery mechanism
it is a highly versatile
technology
that can be engineered for specific
functionalities in gene Therapies now
that a lot of the biology has been
worked out for aav
um it really lends to its versatility as
aging therapy or engine therapy
applications
it is
safe and effective in pre-clinical and
clinical settings as far as we can tell
to this point
um
it does not cause any symptomatic
infection that we know of so there's no
pathology associated with it it can be
used in a wide range range of clinical
applications for multiple diseases due
to its unique background in biophysical
properties
so diving into the uh the critical
aspects
of the molecular biology of aav that is
essential for teen Therapies
aav is as we mentioned a single stranded
DNA virus that encodes two open reading
frames the first open reading frame is
the rep that includes the virus
replication factors as well as the
capsid component which are the viral
capsid proteins VP one two and three as
well as an assembly Factor
the virus itself packages and creates a
full intact virus with helper virus
factors which are provided externally
the aav capsid itself
is composed of monomers of VP one two
and three in a one to one to ten ratio
which produces an isosahedral-shaped
virus
um
with different folds for axis of
symmetry now what's really unique or
really special about aav which makes it
very useful in the gene therapy field is
that everything between the inverted
terminal repeats as displayed here is
packaged and
for the virus in the DNA so knowing what
we know with molecular biology
you can replace
the sequence between the internal the
inverted terminal repeats with a
promoter and a gene of interest and then
in trans you can supply the the rep and
capsid
uh proteins so via A3 plasmid system
which I'll talk about here in a second
to be able to produce intact virus
so as I just said the intact
uh virus is produced in for gene therapy
using a three plasmid system in our
facility and the plasmids are the most
critical material because they contain
the genetic instructions for creating
the serotype specific viral vectors as
well as the therapeutic payload
um the first plasma that is used is the
aav vector so as we showed on our
previous slide and I'll bring this back
up here
um the promoter and the gene of Interest
are included encoded in this in this
vector
the ad the adenovirus helper helps to
put the virus together so it can
contains
um the the helper factors that I had
mentioned earlier and then the aab
helper plasmid is what is going to
contain your rep and Pla your weapon cap
sequences to really help Define what
serotype is going to be used
so at that at this point I'm going to
turn the slide deck over to Samir to
provide some more background
yeah thank you Kevin uh
let's go to the next slide
okay so uh as again mentioned the
essential components of making this Gene
telegraphy Vector are in the three
different plasmids the plasma is
containing the transient of Interest the
ad helper which has the help of virus
factors necessary for packaging it and
aav helper which essentially decides
what stereotype will be used for for
gene therapy uh the next slide shows
that the number of stereotypes that are
currently being used and this is just a
small representative of the stereotypes
that are commonly used now uh this lists
around uh seven or eight but if you look
at the clinical trials uh we have more
than 15 stereotypes currently available
and there is a lot of work which is
currently being done to even make better
flow types the challenges in the field
are firstly why do we make so many
stereotypes the challenges are because
we want to achieve the specificity
anthropism that is required so in order
to prevent any side effects or future
side effects so if you want a stereotype
to be targeting a tissue like lungs you
want it only to go to the lung and not
and minimize any kind of uh targeting to
any other any other cell type so as more
and more capsules become available uh
that becomes another tool to use to make
an effective gentherapy vector so what
we do in our company and I will go
through that briefly into the next few
slides and let's go to the next slide
so this kind of encapsulates in a big
picture what are the required work that
needs to be done before we are able to
manufacture the gene therapy Vector in
large amounts and this is
pretty much belongs to three or four
different departments in our company the
first we start with the plasma again the
goal that we look forward is how to make
an effective gene therapy Vector which
has the minimum uh side effect and which
can be
accepted as for the FDA guidelines to be
introduced into a patient so when we
when we start about uh making these
AV vectors we start with the plasma
and the plasma the
involves the construction of the plasmic
it can be a construction of the vector
plasma which has a gene of Interest the
AV helper classmate uh for the
stereotype and the ad helper plasma
and there's a lot of work which which
goes on behind the scenes for that this
work is done mainly in the discovery
stage which is primarily done with
clients and then we assist in in uh in
that process for the cloning or
engineering of that Vector so uh
the other The genome design as Kevin
mentioned uh carries a gene expression
cassette it has includes the promoter it
has a transgene of Interest it has other
regulatory Elements which ensure uh
appropriate transition
termination and other regulatory factors
which we make sure that we have a proper
gene expression going on without any
side effects due to the elements that
are present there
for example uh one of the things that is
implicit in gene therapy that we when we
introduce a gene into a patient it
should achieve the necessary expression
level
so in design as everyone knows we have
to then design appropriate promoters to
achieve that level
the next is we have to consider where is
Museum going to be delivered
so is that promoter let's say it is
going to be a lung cell or a labor cell
and so on and so forth we want to make
sure that the promoters are appropriate
for that expression there's a lot of uh
background work which goes on not just
in the individual Laboratories but also
in the companies where we try to make
sure that before we manufacture the
vector we have all the elements covered
uh all the regulatory elements should be
in accordance with whether cells are
dividing or non-dividing because AV has
a unique property that it can go into
both dividing cells as well as
non-dividing cells
and that's a huge advantage that we have
so knowledge a prior knowledge of that
helps us design appropriate promoters
and Regulatory elements
from the industry standpoint it is also
critical to assess whether any of these
DNA elements that we are putting in
while designing the vector or the
stereotypes uh plasma is that whether
any of these DNA elements have a tumor
with genetics potential or not and if so
they need to be removed in accordance
with the safety guidelines provided by
the FDA
the other points in consideration for
the plasma design include whether the
expression will lead to toxicity or if
it whether it will trigger any unwanted
immune response and that that kind of
knowledge is that's what some of the
challenges are that goes hand in hand
with what's going on in the Laboratories
annual studies and as the knowledge
comes forth we can keep on improving the
design
so once the design plug is completed the
plastic construction is completed we
then have to worry about plasma
production and purification
and that's where uh every Gene has to be
evaluated uh some genes by Nature are
not expressed in the large amounts some
blockers are not expressed in plasma so
we have the device strategies that's
what we do uh in the industry setting in
the development side of things we make
sure that we have the appropriate self
bacterial cells to produce a plasmid uh
in larger large amounts and then we
purify that so
in the laboratory it might seem not so
uh it might seem trivial to say produce
one milligram of plasma so we are
talking about gram quantity of the
plasma in a very pure uh
the Purity is one of the most important
things and that will come to it later on
because
much of what we do later on
depends on the purity of the plasma so
the whole plasma division takes care of
those issues High expression of
classmates high monoplasm and Purity to
the extent that is accepted the current
guidelines for many companies for Purity
is that it should be at least eighty
percent super quiet
uh image but from experience we can say
the the better the super heavy city of
the classmates the better will will be
in the downstream events remember this
is a this is a transaction event we have
to use this classmates to transfect
cells and there are many considerations
of how a transition transfection will
take place and so the Purity is very
important
so once that is done then the plasmid
comes to our hands to see how well we
can develop the process of making the AV
vector and that's where the next set of
points uh what we consider is
we start with
what is the dose of aav that is required
it depends on the delivery type is it a
targeted delivery to a specific organ or
tissue or is it a systemic delivery and
based on that if you look at clinical
clinical trials and this is where the
challenges are how much of vector is
needed for either of these deliveries so
on average uh if you look at clinical
trials the ranges between uh 10 to the
power of 9 to 10 to the power of 15
Vector genomes per adult dose
and that is calculated based on a lot of
studies uh clinical preclinical studies
it and that's for a targeted uh
injection uh for a systemically this
amount of those goes up uh an average is
anywhere between 10 to the power of 13
to the 10 to the power of 15 Vector
genomes per dollars per adult
so
we have to consider that in while we are
designing a strategy for production of
this vector
again to achieve that the next point is
what sells and what platform to use uh
there are a variety of cells that are
used and that comes to play the most
commonly used cells from the human cell
point is a human embryonic kidney cells
but there are other cells like insect
cells they're also being used to make AV
vectors and then this comes the platform
we decide whether it's going to be an
adherent platform
so we'll use cells which are
growing in a different manner or a
suspension platform which has its own
advantages so and uniqueness about it so
once that this is taken place then we
have to evaluate strategies of
making that amount of vector and uh the
different aspects of that is listed in
this slide
and that would be
we develop strategies to maximize viral
titles that is Upstream development
we developed strategies to purify that
Vector that comes from the downstream
development and while this is going on
hand in hand we are considering what is
the quality of product
when we are using these strategies and
what is the formulation strategy by
formulation strategy we have to consider
what are the different kinds of
foundation buffers which we can put this
virus in after all in the end we will
have to have a formulation which is in
accordance with the FDA guidelines which
will be applicable to a
for injection into a human
so all those all these steps require in
process characterization
once we have a small scale strategy
developed for production of this virus
in the Purity that we want and the
quality that we want we then have to go
to scaling up because that's where it's
at manufacturing is done at very large
scales and a bioreactor format so once
we do a scale up we have to then Define
in that process of a scale up what are
the critical process parameters
what are the ranges and I'll go into
that in the next few slides and what are
the critical quality attributes in that
process so we need to determine what
these points are our goal is to have as
much control over the process
so that we have complete knowledge of
what's going on and what can be the
repercussions of something goes wrong
so as I mentioned hand in hand with
determining the policy are the assets
that are involved in determining what
we've defined as a quality and
that's something of the category of
release assets and Kevin will go through
that in the next uh eventually
once all this is done we do a tech
transfer
Tech transfer is a process where we
transfer our process to the
manufacturing divisions
that is the final step in development
after that we are kind of handing the
keys for large scale production
an assumption is that by the time you
reach the state we have complete
knowledge or as customer as possible
till date
in order to make that Vector after that
it's just production and then going on
to the clinical so in this slide
I'm just going to cover the upstream and
downstream development that is needed uh
prior to us doing a
a transfer to a process to a
manufacturing divisions what we know
already before you start this is what is
the dose needed for the virus what are
the cells we choose and then now we have
to divide the strategy how we can
maximize the title and how we can purify
so what is listed here is a broad view
of strategies that we cover
and we are just examples and I'll
explain that so in order to develop uh
an optimized platform for production and
purification there are a lot of studies
that need to be performed
perhapsing production uh Upstream
development the strategies are we
started the goal a goal is of course to
maximize the title
some of the factors that we have to
cover are what are the cellular factors
that are required for maximizing
production
they'll DNA player role
other media playing a role
since this is a transaction based
process what are the different
transaction reagents that we can play
around well for example when do we
Harvest
so I'll just give you a few examples
from each of these factors
so remember the overall goal is to have
identify factors that will be optimized
to maximize the production if our goal
is to maximize production we can go
through this process by one factor at a
time which is a very prolonged process
but what we do is use a design of
experiments approach which is now pretty
widely accepted in a lot of companies
and also Laboratories in order to
evaluate the effect of multiple factors
at a time the advantage of that is also
weak
with that approach we also understand
how different factors are interacting
with each other if you do one factor at
a time we will not get that as or we
will get that answer after much longer
experimentation than now okay clearly
there is some computational analysis
which is associated with that but that
comes hand in hand when you divide the
strategy so I said let's go to the self
package what self practice can we
consider the cell factors include what
cell density to use that again depends
on the properties of cells that we're
using and insect cell may be different
than and is different from a human cell
what's their stage should be used does
that player role in improving battle
title what cell viability is important
so all these factors are considered so
we devise certain ranges that we cover
in that uh understand the experiment
that way
from the DNA factors it includes
concentrations of plasmids we have a
three plasma system what concentration
to use what ratios are each plasmids use
uh what are the total DNA amounts that
we're going to use all that come into
the design
the media factors include media type
their variety of Medias and I'll come
briefly touch upon that later on uh what
are the different properties of this
media as much as you can know these
media that we buy a proprietary so we
try to work with companies to get admin
information that we will provide to the
FDA in order to have as much control
over the media or not
are there any media additives that need
to be added so all that goes into this
Factor and is that does that play a role
in the overall production
of four dimension transcription really
there are a variety of Transportation
reagents based on lipids based on small
compounds and you name so we have to
choose which translation reagent
we should work with what is the
concentration of that transaction
reagent
does that consultation
depend on the
amount of DNA we use and or amount of
cell we use so translation per DNA
transmission amounts per cell and those
are the transmission reason factors we
include in the experimentation strategy
another Point we've mentioned is when do
we harvest the cells
and these these are just a few other
factors and it may seem daunting but
much of this is governed by the
knowledge that we already have from the
biology of these cells we're not
starting from scratch we are starting
from a body of knowledge which is
developed in a lot of Laboratories in
the world
and we can as you go forward we can add
some factors
physical factors is temperature
important is pH important so on and so
forth
the outcome of that is
once you do this
experiment we get an idea of what factor
is involved and how does it affect the
response uh in this case if you look at
the right side of the uh a brief model
is given this is a response model which
comes out and uh it just shows Factor
one and one axis Factor two in another
axis and the z-axis is tighter so if our
goal is C is to see what is the
variations of fact cell Factor one and
Factor two to maximize the title
we look at the red region
and this is the beginning of a model so
we want to be as much into the red
region so that gives us a a boundary of
what uh Factor One Properties we should
work with what factor two properties we
work with in this model it says that we
should have low level of factor to
that's a factor one and a medium range
of factors to to achieve maximum wire
patterns so a series of experiments like
this then in a small scale a very small
scale will let us identify optimized
factors
to work with once we have that we start
to the next state we have we have
optimized a set of factors which lead to
increased Water Production
now can we use those factors to increase
and see if we can purify those stories
of those viruses so again we can do a
similar set of Downstream development uh
what are the clarifications that we'll
use remember we are not going to be
using in the manufacturing scale we will
be using lead 200 hundreds of liters of
scale we cannot use centrifugation as a
strategy of removing cellular Library so
we use filters clarification filters so
what kind of filters to use do the
player role in the viral quality and the
viral production uh there is a ultra
filtration and the application factors
uh that come in hand how we concentrate
the virus before we go to the
chromatography step it can be of an area
it can be
ion exchange and you name it so we we
cover all those and finally but not the
least other formulation buffer in which
we want to uh concentrate a virus in so
all the similar strategy will tell us
whether
we have an optimized condition that will
lead to us optimize purification
strategy as well
uh as we understand the biology we can
either narrow these factors or we can
increase the factors so
uh
in the next slide yes so
so as we said the next step is the
particles product and that is going hand
in hand we have in the process
development we have to have in process
characterization at each stage we track
not only do we track the wires we also
track where the impurities are being
removed and that is very important for
an FDA point of view for a phase three
point of view so we have more control uh
there are many functional assets we need
to put up with if certain conditions are
leading to aggregation we need to know
that and what a certain conditions lead
to a better
full capsule than empty then we need to
know that so all this is in line with
our analytical capabilities that we have
to assess at each stage
once we have that then we go to scale
that's where we're going when we go to
flask by writer scale there are some
factors that scale dependence so if you
go to for example if you go to
bioreactor factors like impeller speed
gas flows within the bioreactor whether
it's a different bioreactor or a
suspension battery act that come to play
and we optimize that as an as we go
along
once we have that process developed we
need to see if the scales if our
conditions that we optimized are
scalable and that is from the below the
figure below as a representative figure
that when we go from small scale to Big
scale we are having a scalable platform
once this is done and on the right side
is just a representative scsgl but we
have other methods of estimating Purity
which is more quantifiable and more
sensitive uh then we have a process
this process then we have a process this
is ready for the technology transfer
that's in the next slide
and that transfer is is a huge Landmark
for any company so this is the step
which tells us to go to manufacturing
whether it's a research grade
manufacturing pre-clinical or clinical
manufacturing and associated with this
Tech transfer is a huge amount of
documentation which has to go
essentially we are giving the keys for
production everything all the study
reports all the protocols all the Sops
masterbatch records what is a success
success criteria for each stage of
production and detailed testing once
this goes to Tech transfer the
manufacturing division essentially
follows it and produces it
the product the development side then
assesses whether that production was
successful or not based on the
successful success criteria laid out in
the document
and the testing which is uh necessary
for that
so this is the step that we do and I
will pass it over to Kevin here because
the next important stage is the uh
release assays which go hand in hand
with tech transfer and everything else
okay thank you all right thank you Samir
um as Samir mentioned the next steps are
our release assays and many of the
physical and functional characterization
steps that were performed as part of the
in-process testing are also used by our
quality control teams developed by our
analytical development teams for release
of a product
uh as Samir had mentioned as well the
FDA has guidelines associated with
various uh with the biological uh
Therapeutics and the quality of the
product is of utmost important we we
need to understand what the potency is
what the titer is what the infectivity
of the virus is are there any residual
host cell impurities remaining in the
end product
um we have to obviously ensure sterility
you do not want to induce any sort of
immunogenic
properties from from your therapeutic if
it can be avoided
especially due to the product itself
being not being sterile and then the
empty and full as we had mentioned
earlier as well the virus will package
everything that is
present between the inverted terminal
repeats but every once in a while the
virus does does not efficiently package
everything so we we need to know whether
or not the capsules are full or empty
um
so all of these are evaluated as part of
quality control the in-process testing
is typically performed either by quality
control or the analytical development
teams
but from a quality standpoint all of
these do need to be evaluated on the end
product and for late stage
um for for late phase
uh testing as well as for commercial
release
the every one of these tests must be
product specific because as Samir also
mentioned the formulation buffer as well
as each of these processes must be very
well characterized so in a product by
product specific basis
the the FDA needs to know that there
aren't any residual host cell impurities
that the matrices that these products
are produced in are not impacting the
testing that is performed
so on our next slide here we outline the
overall manufacturing process we
segregate between the upstream and the
downstream processes so on the very
early on you have your your good
manufacturing practices but that's what
GMP is you have your raw materials you
have your plasmids that were that are
going to be used your media and the heck
and in this case run it here and sell
platform we're talking our heck 293s
cells but in this case dependent upon
the virus being used or
um the the production method being used
the cell type might vary
uh for the production stage we have our
plasma DNA that's going to be used in
the transfection the media Harvest and
then the Upstream purification processes
that are associated uh following this we
go to production of the filth and fill
finish and this includes the downstream
purification and
um really the finishing and packaging of
of the end product and at this point
quality control is being looped back
into the whole process
um it's not part of the Upstream process
it's now part of the release and all the
tests that were recently outlined are
being characterized the drug substance
itself is being characterized the
release testing of being performed and
then ultimately stability is being
evaluated uh long-term stability is is
essential when when the drug is in the
clinic so these will be evaluated
typically on a month by month basis then
to six months and years down the line
down down the line and then
also environmental monitoring is
included in this to ensure sterility
um some various quality control and
analytical development uh assays that
need to be considered are are in process
testing as we had mentioned earlier for
the production the drug substance
testing as we just mentioned the product
release product stability
um the uh the toxicology studies need to
be produced uh or need to be verified
um if there's if there's device testing
that needs to be performed that that's
also included as well as that
environmental monitoring that we just
mentioned
here I'm not going to read through all
of these but these are any number of
assays that are performed to evaluate uh
from the tire that will be delivered uh
all the way through the impurities of
the associated host uh cell and
production process
and then
um several High uh Studies have
highlighted the biological relevance of
the modifications for transduction
efficiency and tropism but also for
stability so
um
there are certain specialized assays
that are now becoming critical and
they're in development that measure the
changes in post-translational
modifications including glycosylations
and phosphorylations so these are these
are all very very important for the
delivery of
um of pain therapy specifically uh in
this case in biologics in general
um
so
in this case uh we hope we have provided
a pretty high level overview from
concept of a gene therapy to
commercialization uh using a cdmo in our
case
a contract development manufacturing
organization
um
it will ultimately start with the
plasmids move on through development
manufacturing finally to fill finish but
there are a lot of steps and a lot of
integration there along the way that a
researcher should consider very very
early on because again when you're
trying to take the disease that you're
working on and try to develop a
therapeutic for it
um
there even if even if something looks
promising there are a lot of different
steps and a lot of processes along the
way that need to be considered
which takes us back to really why all of
us are working in this field to begin
with and if a patient first mentality
it's very personalized
um if someone is in need of gene therapy
it is a obviously it is a very personal
disease
and that
is why I would like to highlight the
story behind who andolan is
um and I mentioned earlier that this is
all for educational purposes but again I
just really need to emphasize here that
we are all working in this field for the
patients so andelen is named in honor of
two gene therapy patients who
participated in a very
pivotal phase one clinical trial at
Nationwide Children's Hospital Andrew
was eight years old and he received the
first U.S investigational pain therapy
for DMD in 2006 and Evelyn was eight
weeks old who received an experimental
gene therapy for SMA in 2015. so
thinking back on a 2006 and 2015 aren't
that long ago
um the very first gene therapy is
approved were in 2012 and that was in
Europe and then in the United States the
first approved gene therapy was in 2017.
so Andrew and Evelyn where is where
andelen came from but you can see these
were these were phase one or very early
phase clinical trials for very rare
diseases
um
Evelyn I think a time of diagnosis was
not expected to live beyond uh two years
old
um and she is still alive to this day
she visited our facility
um just it was last summer so things are
going very well for these uh two for
these two children
um and again patient patient first is
really the reason that all of us are in
the gene therapy field and then
we would like to open it up to questions
uh Samira and I apologize that we will
not be able to be there when this
presentation is aired
um but we would encourage you to reach
out to us at our email addresses here
and we would be happy to
take any questions that you might have
and we look forward to hearing from you
hopefully this is informational thank
you very much
thank you Dr acharya and Dr McGarry for
your time today and your important
research before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until April 6 2024.
loudreads will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye